"ANGLE."
MEMBERS OF THE ANTI-TRUMP ARE
DELITHE  -- DELIGHTING IN A WAR
OF RECORDS BETWEEN STEVE BANNON
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BANNON SUGGESTED THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS AWARE OF THE 2016
BANNON SAID THE CHANCE DON JR.
DIDN'T WALK THE PEOPLE UP TO HIS
FATHER'S OFFICE IS ZERO.
BANNON DIDN'T JOIN THE CAMPAIGN
UNTIL 2 MONGST LATER.
THIS SET OFF A FEEDING FRENZY IN
THE MEDIA.
WILL CRACKDOWN JR. LIKE AN EGG.
JARED KUSHNER WAS ALSO CALLED
OUT BY BANNON.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT MONEY
LAUNDERING.
THEY GO THROUGH PAUL MANAFORT
AND JARED KUSHNER.
IT'S AS PLAIN AS THE HAIR ON
BLUNT STATEMENT.
HE SAID STEVE BANNON HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH ME AND MY PRESIDENCY.
WHEN HE WAS FIRED ISSUE HE NOT
ONLY LOST HIS JOB, HE LOST HIS
MIND.
AND:
OKAY.
HERE'S MY ADVICE.
I AM PLAYING DR. PHIL OR JUDGE
JUDY HERE.
SOME QUESTIONS:
WHO DOES THIS HELP?
DOES THIS ADVANCE THE
CONSECUTIVE POPULACE AGENDA AT
ALL?
WHAT IS GOING THROUGH BOTH
SIDE'S MINDS.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE HEAD OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT'S NOT BANNON OR ME.
IT'S DONALD TRUMP.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OF THE
IMPEACH TRUMP FORCES.
BANNON PROBABLY WON HIMSELF A
TRIP TO TESTIFY ON CAPITOL HILL.
IS THAT WHAT BANNON WANTS?
I KNOW STEVE BANNON.
IS THAT WHAT HE WANTS?
IF THERE IS A POLICY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TRUMP AND BANNON HAVE AN
EXCHANGE.
FELLOWS, IT DIDN'T REALLY MAKE
SENSE FOR A HIGH-PROFILE ADVISOR
AND HIS FORMER BOSS TO ATTACK
EACH OTHER WHEN THE STEAKS ARE
THIS HIGH.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
AREN'T YOU PLAYING RIGHT INTO
THE HAND OF THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA WHO ARE HOPING FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOT HOW WE SAW THIS STORY
DEVELOPING.
ON TO MORE IMPORTANT MATTERS.
THERE WAS A BIG MEETING BETWEEN
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS OF BOTH
PARTIES AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY
DREAMERS BROUGHT INTO THE
COUNTRY BY THEIR PARENTS OR SENT
TO THE COUNTRY ON THEIR OWN.
IT'S A NEGOTIATION THAT IS
SCHEDULE TO CONTINUE TOMORROW.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE INVOLVED
ACTION, DACA, HE ALLOWED ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE TO STAY AND WORK IN
THE COUNTRY FOR ROLLING 2-YEAR
PERIODS.
IN FACT, IF 2017, EVEN DURING
DREAMERS APPLIED FOR AND
RECEIVED DACA STATUS.
SO OBAMA'S POLICY LIVED ON.
LAST SEPTEMBER TRUMP SAID HE
WOULD END THE PROGRAM.
THEN HE GAVE CONGRESS 6 MONTHS
TO FIND THEIR ONLY SLOGS.
-- SOLUTION.
KIND OF SMART.
TRUMP DEMANDED THAT LAWMAKERS
PASS RESPONSIBLE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
WHAT MIGHT THAT LOOK LIKE?
WELL, THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN US
A FEW CLUES ALREADY.
>> THIS KID CAME IN THROUGH A
LOTTERY SYSTEM.
I INSTRUCTED CONGRESS THEY MUST
END IT.
>> CHAIN MIGRATION IS A HUGE
PROBLEM.
>> MORE OF THOSE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
CHAIN MIGRATION IS A DISASTER
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
TELL END.
>> WILL BE IT PART OF THE
DREAMER DEAL?
>> YES, PART OF THE DACA DEAL.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT IS ON
THE RIGHT TACK.
WE MUST FUND THE WALLAND HIRES
THOUSANDS MORE ICE AGE AGENTS TO
BY HALF.
THE DREAMER NIGHTMARE IS UPON
US.
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IS CONGRESS
PASSES AMNESTY.
MORE UNACCOMPANIED ALIEN
CHILDREN ARE COMING ACROSS NOW
TODAY.
WHY ARE THE NUMBERS GOING UP?
DREAMERS.
ALL OF THE BENEFITS OF HEALTH
CARE, EDUCATION AND HOUSING.
FOREIGNERS SEE THE GREEN LIGHT
HERE.
ACCORDING TO THE LAST 2 MONTHS
OF AVAILABLE STATS, WE HAVE SEEN
A SURGE -- 7,000 UNACCOMPANIED
THEY CAN'T BE DEPORTED TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRY UNDER CURRENT U.S.
LAW.
INTO THE U.S., BECOMING OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
GIVEN THAT WE -- JUST THINK
ABOUT THIS.
JUST ONE METRIC, THOUSANDS OF
HOMELESS U.S. VETERANS ON THE
STREETS TONIGHT SHIVERING IN THE
COLD WITH NO ONE TO CARE FOR
THEM WITH ADDICTION PROBLEMS AND
MENTAL ISSUES.
THEY ARE ON THE STREETS, BUT WE
ARE CATERING TO THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THAT'S THE PRIORITY OF CONGRESS.
IN IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE WILL EXPLAIN THE EFFECTS OF
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
COULD SWAMP THE COUNTRY.
THE FAILURE OF REPUBLICANS TO
PROTECT AND SECURE THE BORDER
CAUGHT THEM DEARLY AT THE BALLOT
BOX FOR SEVERAL CYCLES.
THEIR EFFORTS TO CATER TO THE
VIOLATORS OF OUR LAWS AT THE
REASONS DONALD TRUMP GOT ELECTED
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF AMERICANS MAKE SOME QUICKIE